we start today with the humiliatingly
abortive presidential campaign
announcement of Republican Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis this event was a
global humiliation and if DeSantis
presidential campaign is going to follow
the theme and tone and competence of
yesterday's Twitter spaces announcement
it is going to be a very very
short-lived campaign now let's not judge
it all by the first 24 hours but it was
really bad for those of you who don't
know there was an announcement made two
days ago that Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis after much speculation would
indeed announce that he is running for
president in the Republican Party
against Donald Trump and Tim Scott and
Nikki Haley and Vivek ramaswamy and he
would be making this announcement
alongside Elon Musk on Twitter spaces
Twitter spaces is a very rudimentary I
mean we're talking about audio over the
Internet this isn't the most advanced
you know 4K live streaming video you
could imagine so low energy nearly a
dozen technical disasters I'm starting
to think prayer may work because I was
willing technical disasters into
existence all day yesterday and they
happen so I have to reconsider maybe
thoughts and prayers actually do have an
impact I'm kidding of course this was
the worst and most embarrassing
presidential campaign launch that I can
remember
in the modern political era minutes of
silence random throat clearing muffled
commentary from Elon Musk about how the
servers are melting down DeSantis
himself getting booted off of the event
let's just listen to a little bit of and
again I'm there are going to be extended
silences here I'm trying to get
everybody back in the mode of
understanding the environment yesterday
which we live streamed and just
everything going wrong let's jump into
it
it is now live okay so it's starting
about eight minutes late and this is the
sort of thing that we experienced
32 000 people are
all right great so let's see let's just
keep crashing huh
yeah I think we've got a just a massive
number of people online so it's um
service restraining somewhat
um it's not clear they know they're live
right now that's Elon Musk by the way
speaking
it's shocking to me they didn't bring in
Mike pillows cyber guys to help
mm-hmm
take it all in my friends take it all in
normally this this the David Pacman show
doesn't include such extended silences
but the the content is the silence in
this particular case
they seem to have no idea that this is
all live
okay it got even worse if you can
believe it when they sort of like got
closer to actually starting
let's see so here we go yeah I think so
um just to simplify that
so then they cut out
when they seem to realize they were
going to be starting they cut out again
this went on for about half hour
I think we're just gonna use your
as you can see it's just not good
okay and then there were like audio
feedback loops and all sorts of things
now there are we're going to get to the
DeSantis speech in a moment
there are people like Ben Shapiro
right-wing columnist uh commentator Ben
Shapiro saying things like what he
tweeted quote tonight was a perfect
encapsulation of the campaign if you're
obsessed with the Optics of the Twitter
spaces glitch then you're probably not
going to vote DeSantis if you're
interested in political substance
DeSantis is likely your candidate there
were also people on the right saying
this isn't a disaster this event was so
popular that it crashed Twitter servers
so many people were interested that it
crashed Twitter servers it is a big
success all of these narratives are
idiotically wrong first and foremost
once DeSantis started speaking it got
even worse he read a prepared speech
with absolutely no Charisma or
engaging inflection or delivery which
just talked about woke and he whined so
once DeSantis started speaking there was
no substance it was just grievances in
an even whinier voice than the one
Donald Trump speaks in and for this
entire like it wasn't a disaster so many
people were interested that it crashed
the servers this is a success number one
not even a million people this was
promoted for 30 hours everywhere
nationally every play Fox was talking
about it CNN MSNBC every newspaper
everybody was talking about this
and they scrounge together at its peak
900 000 people that's not exactly a
rousing success and the whole story
about Elon musk's takeover of Twitter is
he's the tech guy he's going to rebuild
the stack remember that we're going to
rebuild the stack completely from the
ground up we've we've gotten rid of all
of the Superfluous Engineers now Twitter
is operating beautifully this is just
audio over the Internet it's not even
video and they couldn't hold it together
so the it was such a success that it
crashed is not a viable line now
DeSantis eventually did start speaking
and he somehow figured out a way to be
even more whiny than Trump during his
campaign launch which is really Bonker
stuff he used the word woke I think more
than 20 times I lost count our live
audience lost count here's sort of what
the the speech sounded like Biden's
allowed woke ideology to drive his
agenda we will never surrender to the
woke mob and we will leave woke ideology
in the Dustbin of history there you go
so woke woke you know it remember when
Rudy Giuliani was uh 911 noun verb Ron
DeSantis is woke noun verb that's what
that's what it is a humiliation for Elon
Musk that cannot be understated nothing
worked and once DeSantis actually got to
speak it was the lowest energy campaign
announcement I could imagine
the political Alliance also shouldn't be
ignored Elon Musk who says his number
one priority in buying Twitter and
making the changes to Twitter that he
made is Free Speech
and he's making a big show of
celebrating Ron DeSantis who is quite
literally Banning books in school
libraries and suppressing the speech of
teachers and corporations in Florida
that's the alliance that we have here
this event was so bad even Donald Trump
looked clever and funny in trolling
DeSantis and I want to talk about that
next one of our sponsors today is Bon
charge I have always enjoyed dry saunas
you get in there your heart rate is up
dilates the blood vessels can soothe
achy joints and muscles it's relaxing
it's just a great way to remove a little
stress Bon charge is the creator of the
infrared sauna blanket which you can
enjoy from home super easy to set up
heats up fast you don't have to have
your head inside like at a traditional
sauna at the gym nice for meditating or
reading getting work done relaxing I
have found it to be a great way to
unwind at the end of a long day easy to
clean Sleek lightweight design easy to
store and comes with a 12 month warranty
and of course if you don't love it
returns are super easy but I think you
will love it and you'll get 15 off when
you go to boncharge.com Pacman and use
the code Pacman the link is down below